[Music]  Ben Ouma from oujda wants to know where  does the sand on the beach come from  beaches can be crowded or empty and  remote and the sand is great for  building castles and sculptures you can  also build islands with sand like this  one in Dubai  most of it actually originates in  mountains humans have to work very hard  to break up pieces of stone while nature  does it more elegantly if more slowly  when water enters gaps in stone and  freezes it eventually splits the rock  the pieces that fall off are carried  away by streams and rivers to the sea  the process of erosion continues as the  stones rub against each other along the  way in the tropics parrotfish also play  a major role in the formation of sandy  beaches they chew on coral and then poop  the gritty bits out again ocean currents  transport the fragments of coral to the  shore waves dump them on the beach along  with large quantities of sand from the  seabed  you